Nanoroboter im Blut, Autos, die
sich sieben Mal überschlagen
und Flammen, die aus einem Tunnel kommen.
Wie real James Bond ist, das haben wir gecheckt.
Tach zusammen, Pop hier. Jack Pop.
„Keine Zeit zu sterben“ ist gerade
in den Kinos angelaufen und auch, wenn
James Bond jetzt kein Superheld mit
irgendwelchen übernatürlichen Kräften
ist, er ist trotzdem in Superagent.
(Sie können sich ja so denken,
warum ich wieder mitspiele.)
Das heißt, auch er hat ganz spezielle
Fähigkeiten. Und deswegen sind wir
heute im Auftrag Ihrer Majestät unterwegs und
geben Daniel Craig, zum Abschied seiner Ära,
noch einmal einen gebührenden Reality-Check mit.
Das machen wir heute gleich mit drei smarten
Expertinnen, nämlich mit Anna vom
Youtube-Kanals So Many Tabs, mit meinem
Lieblingsphysiker Henry und mit Martin Lederer.
Der ist Stuntkoordinator hier im Filmpark
Babelsberg. Aber am Anfang seid Ihr erstmal
gefragt. Schreibt mir mal in die Kommentare,
welcher ist Euer Lieblings-Bond? Sean Connery,
Roger Moore? Lasst mal eine Geheimnotiz da.
Daniel Craig hatte seinen ersten Auftritt 2006
im Film Casino Royal. Und in diesem Film gibt
es einen Stunt, der so spektakulär ist, dass er es
sogar ins Guinness-Buch der Rekorde geschafft hat.
Da sieht James Bond das Bond-Girl Vesper Lynd
auf der Straße liegen, weicht ihr aus und dabei
überschlägt sich sein Wagen nicht einmal, nicht
zweimal, sondern ganze siebenmal. Wenn wir jetzt
schauen wollen, ob das in der Realität möglich
wäre, dann brauche ich ein bisschen Hilfe. Und
was für James Bond Q ist, das ist für mich… Henry!
Ein alkoholfreies Wodka-Wermut-Mischgetränk. Ist
das gerüttelt?
Geschnürt.
So mag ich es. Henry ist so ein
krasser Überschlag überhaupt möglich?
Dazu müssen wir uns wieder die Kräfte angucken,
die auf das Auto wirken. Hier wirkt die
Gewichtskraft und die Zentrifugalkraft,
weil das Auto ja in die Kurve fährt.
Und Kurven und Kräfte haben wir auch in
unserer Mario-Kart Folge schon besprochen.
Da waren noch eine Menge Bananen mit dem
Spiel. Schaut Die Euch bitte unbedingt an,
die verlinke ich Euch hier oben.
Aber wir wollen uns jetzt auf die Physik
konzentrieren. Was braucht es jetzt ganz genau,
damit der Aston Martin von James Bond abhebt?
Diese beiden Kräfte versuchen jetzt, das Auto um
den äußeren Reifen zu kippen. Die Zentrifugalkraft
kippt es nach außen und die Gewichtskraft versucht
es wieder zurückzukippen. Diese beiden Kräfte
greifen im Schwerpunkt an. Jetzt ist noch wichtig,
wie groß ist denn der Hebelarm der beiden Kräfte?
Der Hebelarm bestimmt, wie groß die Dreh-
oder Kippwirkung von einer Kraft ist.
Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Türen, wo
die Türklinke ganz außen ist. Weil,
wenn ich die da aufmache, ist die Hebelwirkung
groß, die Tür geht leicht auf. Wenn die Türklinke
weiter innen wäre, müsste ich viel mehr
Kraft aufbringen, um die aufzumachen.
Ganz genau. Und für das Auto wäre der
Hebelarm dieser Gewichtskraft die halbe
Autobreite und für die Zentrifugalkraft
ungefähr ein Drittel der Autohöhe.
Wenn jetzt also die Kipp-Wirkung
der Zentrifugalkraft größer ist als
die der Gewichtskraft, Dann kippt
das Auto um und überschlägt sich.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt ausrechnen wollen,
ob das physikalisch möglich ist, dann müssen
wir schauen, wie breit und wie hoch der Wagen ist,
um eben diesen Schwerpunkt genau zu lokalisieren.
Und dann die Hebelwirkung der verschiedenen
Kräfte rauszukriegen. Und da habe ich beim
Hersteller nachgeschaut. Der Aston
Martin ist 1,90m breit, 1,28m hoch
und mit diesen Werten können wir rechnen.
So machen wir das. Und zwar setzen wir erst
mal unsere Formeln in diese Ungleichung ein.
Die Zentrifugalkraft ergibt sich aus Masse
mal der Geschwindigkeit zum Quadrat geteilt
durch Kurvenradius und die Gewichtskraft über
Masse mal Erdbeschleunigung. Da sehen
wir schon, die Masse kürzt sich raus.
Und da kommt es auch auf zwei Dinge an…
… Leben und sterben lassen…
Fast! Geschwindigkeit und Kurvenradius. Das heißt,
man muss entweder besonders schnell unterwegs sein
oder die Kurve ist halt einfach sehr eng.
Genau. Wenn wir uns die Filmszene angucken,
da sieht er Vespa ungefähr 30m vor sich auf der
Straße liegen. Er fährt in einem Abstand von einem
Meter an ihr vorbei. Und mit diesen beiden
Werten kann man jetzt ausrechnen, wie groß
der Kurvenradius ist. Wenn man das macht, kommt
man auf einen Radius von ungefähr 450m. Und wenn
wir das jetzt in unsere Ungleichung einsetzen,
kommen wir auf eine Geschwindigkeit von 357 km/h.
Superschnell. Da könne man jetzt sagen, man
lebt nur zweimal. Auf einer Landstraße möchte
ich so nicht unterwegs sein. Und dazu kommt,
es ist auch technisch gar nicht möglich,
denn der Aston Martin hat eine
Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 340
km/h. Das heißt, der kommt gar nicht erst auf
die Geschwindigkeit und wir sehen auch nicht,
dass es da irgendwie bergab geht. Da
müssen wir sagen, es wäre unrealistisch.
Jetzt hat der Stunt aber tatsächlich stattgefunden
und er ist sogar im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde
vermerkt. Also irgendeinen Trick haben
die sich da einfallen lassen. Und der
Stuntfahrer selbst hat gesagt, dass er so 100
- 110 km/h gefahren ist. Also deutlich weniger,
als wir eigentlich bräuchten.
Er hat aber im richtigen Moment
eine Luftdruckkanone ausgelöst und
die hat einen Eisenbolzen aus dem Auto
rausgeschossen. Und dadurch hat es so einen
extra Kick bekommen, der Zentrifugalkraft
wurde hier geholfen und das Auto hat dadurch
eben diese ganzen Überschläge hingekriegt.
Das heißt, sie haben bei Casino
Royal geschummelt. Offensichtlich.
2015 kam „Spectre“ in die Kinos und gleich am
Anfang packt Q ein Gadget aus, das Smart-Blood.
Das ist eine Art GPS-Tracking System, aber
im Nanoformat. Also so klein, dass sie das
Bond direkt in die Adern injizieren können.
Das ist eine saugruselige Überwachungsfantasie und
ich sage mal so: Computerchips im Blut, das war
ja während der Corona-Zeit eine relativ beliebte,
wenn auch bekloppte Verschwörungstheorie.
Also wenn wir jetzt mal schauen wollen,
ob es so Mini-GPS-Tracker wirklich geben
könnte, dann müssen wir jemanden fragen,
die sich ich damit auskennt. Nämlich
Anne vom YouTube-Kanal „So Many Tabs“.
Hey Jack! GPS ist ja ein satellitengestütztes
Navigationssystem und das Witzige ist,
die meisten Leute denken, dass Satelliten dich
finden. Aber eigentlich ist es genau umgekehrt.
Der GPS-Tracker findet den Satelliten, und mit
den Informationen von den Satelliten kann er dann
den Standort berechnen. Und das Ganze passiert nur
lokal auf dem GPS-Tracker. Q sagt in dieser Szene,
dass er Bond überall auf der Welt tracken kann.
Es stimmt auch, dass GPS an jedem Punkt der
Erdoberfläche funktioniert. Aber das heißt
noch nicht, dass die Daten auch an Q versendet
werden können. Dafür muss man zum Beispiel mit dem
Mobilfunknetz Daten versenden. Und das könnte auch
problematisch sein, wenn Bond wie in „Spectre“
gerade in der marokkanischen Wüste sitzt.
Oder halt hier in Deutschland.
Das flächendeckende Mobilfunknetz ist hier
also die Schwachstelle. Aber wenn wir das jetzt
hätten, wenn wirklich das Netz die ganze Welt
abdecken würde, könnte es dann Smart-Blood geben?
Nicht so klein, dass er in eine Blutbahn passt.
Das hier ist ein aktueller GPS-Tracker. Das
Modul an sich ist nur ein paar Millimeter groß,
ungefähr wie eine Cent-Münze. Die gibt es aber
auch noch in kleiner. Dazu kommen aber noch
der Akku und die Antenne. Und da kann man
nicht mehr besonders viel kleiner werden.
Da hat Q wohl so einiges nicht bedacht.
Ich sag mal so: für Bond ist es ja jetzt
auch nicht das Schlechteste, wenn er nicht
überall auf der Welt getrackt werden kann.
Wenn ich das Thema interessiert, So Many Tabs
haben gerade ein ganzes Video zur Handy-Ortung
in Filmen rausgehauen. Da geht zum Beispiel
auch darum, ob man ein Handy mit einer Chipstüte
abschirmen kann, so wie im Film Terminator.
Das verlinke ich Euch wie immer hier oben.
Fürs Grande Finale schauen wir jetzt noch
mal bei „Skyfall“ rein. Der Film ist nach dem
Haus benannt, in dem James Bond aufgewachsen
ist. Dieses Haus geht dann auch am Ende des
Films in einem riesigen Feuerball auf.
Bonn selbst zündet die Explosion und
flieht dann durch einen Geheimtunnel
aus dem Haus raus. Aber die Flammen,
die verfolgen ihn in diesem Tunnel, er versteckt
sich, und natürlich überlebt er das Ganze.
Und wenn wir jetzt wissen wollen, ob das
realistisch ist, also ob ein Haus wirklich
durch eine Explosion so krass in Flammen
aufgehen kann und ob man abhauen und sich
vor den Flammen verstecken kann, dann müssen
wir jemanden fragen, der täglich im Angesicht
des Todes mit Explosionen zu tun hat. Und das
ist Martin Lederer von der Stuntcrew Babelsberg.
Martin, schön, dass wir bei Euch sein können.
Ihr kennt Euch aus mit Gasexplosionen und das
ist auch das, was wir in dieser Filmszene sehen.
Da sind zwei Gaskartuschen, die dann hochgehen.
Frage an Dich als Fachmann, wieviel ist da drin?
Also diese Gasbehälter, die wir im Film sehen,
sind genormte Flaschen. Es
sind elf Kilo in jeder Flasche,
also 22 insgesamt, wenn sie voll waren.
Und wenn ihr die jetzt hochjagt,
22 Kilo, würde das jetzt reichen, um ein Haus
in diesem Ausmaß in Flammen aufgehen zu lassen?
Wir haben mal was vorbereitet.
Wir probieren es einfach mal aus,
und dann kannst du selber entscheiden.
Okay, ich habe mega bock drauf. Das heißt,
wir nehmen die Menge aus dem Film,
jagen die in die Luft, gucken, wie es
aussieht, … aber das machen wir nicht hier, oder?
Wir gehen lieber ein Schritt. Los geht's.
Ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Wir machen das jetzt ja?
Hier ist alles vorbereitet. Ich
zähle runter. Alle bereit? 3, 2, 1.
Das war die Menge an James Bond-Gas, die wir jetzt
in die Luft gejagt haben. Es ist schon ordentlich
warm im Gesicht geworden, Martin, aber also so
richtig krass wie mit diesem Haus, wo die Flammen
noch meterweit daneben gehen war es jetzt nicht.
Nee, war es tatsächlich nicht, Wir haben hier ein
offenes Setting, die Flamme geht überall
hin, wo sie eine Öffnung findet und davon
hat sie hier viele. In einem Haus hat
sie die nicht. Aber um das Haus so in
die Luft zu jagen, wie sie es im Bond-Film
gemacht haben, musst du viel mehr tricksen.
Man hätte dann quasi, wenn wir es
jetzt ernst nehmen und in die Realität
übersetzen wollen, hätte James Bond auch
mehr Gas gebraucht, um das so hinzukriegen?
Damit das Haus am Ende genauso explodiert,
hätte er wesentlich mehr gebraucht.
Fakt ist, die Menge, diese 22 Kilo, Die hätten so
nicht gereicht. Und dann ist ja noch die Frage,
ob er sich einfach so vor den Flammen
verstecken kann, in einem Tunnel.
Da geht er da in so einen Seitengang, und dann
ziehen die an ihm vorbei. Wäre das möglich?
Wir haben ja verschiedene Faktoren, die damit
reinspielen. Also einerseits ist die Flamme
wahnsinnig schnell. Ich bezweifele, dass er
so schnell gewesen wäre, sich da wirklich
zu verstecken. Die Hitzeentwicklung. Es wird
wahnsinnig warm. Du hast hier schon gemerkt in
der Entfernung, wie warm es ist. Und dann hast
du natürlich auch noch den Faktor Sauerstoff.
Also die Flamme zieht den Sauerstoff. Und
gerade in so einer beschränkten Umgebung,
wie in so einem Tunnel oder sowas,
bezweifele ich, dass er da viel Spaß
gehabt hätte. Wenn das wirklich so gewesen wäre.
Okay, da kann man hier zumindest festhalten. Mit
der Menge Gas, die uns da präsentiert wurde,
wäre die Explosion so nicht möglich gewesen in
der Realität. Und Bond hätte sich auch nicht
in diesem Tunnel verstecken können. Er hätte
sich mehr als ein seiner Goldfinger verbrannt.
Fassen wir zusammen: Mini-Roboter in unserem
Blut. Die gibt es zum Glück noch nicht. Und auch
bei den anderen Stunts, da müssen wir festhalten.
James Bond hat vielleicht die Lizenz zum Töten,
aber nicht die Lizenz zum Naturgesetze überlisten.
Da haben die Stuntleute einfach ordentlich
und professionell nachgeholfen. Und es ist
ja auch das, was wir sehen wollen; spektakuläre
Bilder. Und ich hoffe, Ihr habt die im Kino,
wenn Ihr Euch den neuen Film reinzieht
Ich sage danke an Martin von der Stuntcrew
Babelsberg, danke an Henry und danke an
Anne vom Kanal So Many Tabs fürs erklären.
Flitzt mal zu denen rüber und lasst von
uns ein paar Liebesgrüße aus Moskau da.
Ich würde mich auf jeden Fall freuen,
wenn ihr nicht vergesst, diesen Kanal zu
abonnieren und die Glocke zu drücken. Dann
können wir uns nämlich bald wiedersehen.
Ich freue mich drauf bis dahin, ciao, ciao!
(Machst du den Imagefilm für Henrys Jugendweihe?)
(Alle elf Minuten verliebt sich ein
Single in Dr. Henry Holland-Moritz.)